Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast and Ahhh
Just checking.
Just checking in on you.
You fucking who? What's
going on? How are you?
Um, oh, it's the sound.
Sound fucked up here.
In order as you guys probably
want a white pill, why don't you,
when you get the fucking sound
right, why don't you just set it,
set it and forget it. Remember
that Shit you turn on an oven.
Just forget about it. Just
fucking walk away from it.
I bought one of those things. That
thing was this shit. I don't know.
I can't remember whatever happened to it.
Stick a whole fucking chicken in
there, you know? And I would shut it,
but I would not forget it.
I would always remember that I had a
chicken cooking cause I was living in New
York and uh, you know,
I was paying nine grand a month for like
fucking 30 square feet. So, you know,
I had my pillow propped up on the
other side of it. And you know,
it's impossible not to hear that bell go
off considering my head was against it.
You know,
half of my head would be sweaty and red
and I'd sit down and eat a whole chicken
greasy shit.
I don't understand why fucking chickens
is so God damn greasy. You know,
when you look at them, they don't look
greasy and that grease is shit. And then,
you know,
what's the worst is you fucking show up
and the amount of people that don't know
how to cook chicken and it's just
fucking dry ass chicken. Do you know,
way back in the day, back in the day
when I was young and I had more hair,
um, I used to do a what was
called the uptown shows,
you know, do the uptown show at town.
You know, in my business is means, uh,
the black shows,
these shows where the crowd
is African American and uh,
every once in is like one white guy
on the show at one token white guy.
So I used to be the token
white guy on those things.
And I remember all the fucking time I
used to do these things and I hope he
hears this. I used to work for a talent.
He used to do all those fucking rooms
and they used to always give me shit,
say white people don't know how
to have a cookout or barbecue,
whatever the fucking thing is. And
I'll never forget, he invited me,
I can't remember, was him a Gerald Kelly.
They invited me up way the fuck up in
the Bronx. I Dunno where the hell I was.
It was just fucking like basketball
slash do stand up during the day in this
basketball park. So I got fuck
it. I'll go up there and do it.
So I went up there, you know, and then
fucking cooking out and all that shit.
And I gotta tell you,
I will never forget how fucking
disappointed I was when I ate the chicken.
It was so fucking dry. Tell
you everybody talks shit.
Uh, fuck it. Do this. I'll
fucking go fucking do it.
Yeah,
I got it. Oh, you know what?
I should have Nia here for this
cause that's another one too.
They always telling me
how good soul food is.
I've been to one good soul food place.
It's the same thing
with like barbecue too.
Everybody Raven above fucking barbecue.
90% of those things are absolute
shit holes. You walk in there,
you see like 50 health code
violations is fucking flies and stuff
and then they just, they try to disguise
all their fuck ups with like fucking,
you know, 10 pounds of
barbecue sauce. I mean,
you put barbecue sauce on a tree branch.
It's gonna fucking taste
good to some level. Right.
Um,
I found that all, you
know, trying to, you know,
you want the reality is is I don't know
shit about barbecue. So it's just like,
you know, if you don't
know shit about standup,
you're going to watch a bunch of
hacks before you get to a good one.
So maybe that's what it is. I
have no idea. I have no idea.
The one place soul food place
that I want that actually,
I went to Amy roofs a long
time ago and I liked that.
I thought that that was quality. All
right. So I know it has to be out there.
I mean, God knows if you want to get
a good fucking corn beef sandwich,
I know the go down to Tom Burgins
here in fucking La, right?
I know where to go for that shit.
So somebody helped me out in la.
Where's was it? Was it good spot for
all of that type of stuff? Cause I've,
I can't say it because
it'd be sacrilegious,
but I've gotten the
most famous fucking, um,
I guess so food place out
here. There's two locations.
And I went to both of them and the
food. Absolutely. Without a doubt.
No questions. Landslide fucking sucked.
And I was like, why is there a God?
Why is there a fucking line around the
block for this shit? It's terrible.
There has to be, this has to be the
spot that only guys like me know about.
Right? And then everybody else
is going to the real place.
Um,
that was a fucking left turn.
I think the only good barbecue I think
I ever really enjoyed was when I was in
Alabama and there was
a place called a size
smart ass Wilson. It's still stood for
and that shit was fucking delicious.
You go in and the place
was clean, you know,
they always have to have it be a little
bit funky. It kind of looks like,
do you guys build hot rods here or are
you, are you making a fucking, you know,
brisket, you know,
fucking pisses me off those wherever you
watch the food network and you watched
those professionals doing it, I'm always
screaming at the TV, where do you,
where the fuck is your restaurant?
I don't want to sit here and watch you
cook and all this shit that I can't
fucking eat. I mean it's
works of art, you know? Yeah.
People will make barbecue or
some fat motherfuckers though.
You gotta admit that, right? Just big
fuck. They look like they drive trucks.
Um,
anyways, this is just making
me hungry. Speaking of which,
I've been eating like shit, you know,
I know it's going to fucking
tell you something. I mean,
what the Hell is talking about? Start
talking about fucking dry chicken. Okay.
So fuck right. Does it really
matter? I'm just checking in on you.
This is really isn't even a podcast.
Um,
anyways, what did I want
to talk about? Oh yeah,
so give you the update on my, uh,
yeah. Fuck that. I'll do that later.
I, um, I fucking drank so
much the other night, right?
I had some friends of mine, they were
at this bar and they texted me going,
hey man, we're out here drinking.
Right? And I didn't want to drink,
which is really surprised. I
mean, I always want to drink,
but I knew I shouldn't,
something in my head and my big
stupid Charlie Brown head said,
don't go to the bar. Right? So I
just, you know, they like, yeah,
we've been day drinking, we're
already here, Yada, Yada, Yada.
And I'm just like, okay, blah,
blah, blah, blah, whatever. Right.
I'm not going to, you know, you know, I
got a set tonight. They're like, yeah,
we're right up the street. Hit us
up after. And I was just like, okay.
And I was just hoping they were going
to be totally hammered and forget.
And I went down to the comedy store.
I've been doing sets all week cause I got
those huge shows this weekend. And um,
I went up ahead a fucking great
set, got all this new shit,
really excited about it, you know,
because I did just do a Gig in downtown
La and one of my gigs is out in
Riverside. The other
one's in Orange County.
My agents telling me this is
a completely different market.
There's a completely different flat
[inaudible] and I'm just worried that
somebody from the show, New
Year's is going to show up.
So I gotta make sure I got a new 15,
20 so they don't be like
[inaudible] same shit. Right?
Like I'm supposed to write a brand
new whack in 90 fucking days.
It's not even 90 days,
you know. So anyways, um,
wow.
I'm working on that shit. And the
second I get off stage, I have a text,
hey man, you off you off off stage
yet for right down the street.
So like a fucking ass hole.
Don't listen to my gut.
I go down there, right.
And I show up and it's everybody that I
like to drink with and I'm like, fuck.
And I'm driving, right? So I go,
I'm going to have one whiskey,
I'm going to nurse it and
that's going to be it. Okay.
And I sipped it and it tasted fucking
delicious. And I literally looked at the,
another comic goes, yeah, I go, why does
it taste so good? And he just laughed.
He goes, it tastes better every year.
And that's kind of the last coherent,
like part of the night that I remember
I sucked at one down and then the
waitress came by and she goes, hey, gay
gay, right? How's, yeah, your house?
And I was, she didn't say, you know, she
was actually, you know, completely, uh,
probably probably did
better in school than I did.
And I'm making fun of her because I'm
set with the answer that I gave her.
I said yes, as my brains gone.
Don't do this bill. Don't do this.
The second you get the second one,
now you have to fucking take a taxi home
and you've got to leave your car here.
Don't do that. Just
fucking relax. You know,
you're really just here
for the social thing.
Just have a water and
talk to the fellas. Right.
So that's what I'm thinking. And my
brain just goes, yes, a mouth goes,
I would like another drink. And then
that it, and then I just looked at it,
buddy, go, well, I'm not driving
now. And they'd go, yeah, yeah,
you're not driving. You're not
driving. And then that was it. And um,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Then somebody told the fucking story
about this drink called the John Riley and
I kept thinking it was like
the, the actor John C. Reilly.
So I kept picturing his,
his face as the guy was telling
the story and I'm going like,
John c Riley's got his, I already
has a drink named bathroom. That's,
that's like the, like the bar version
of women, like the Mark Twain Award.
Right. And I'm like, good for John.
And it wasn't until he got
like halfway through the story,
I realized he was just talking
about a guy, John Riley,
Eddie date fucking did something.
He fought one of those,
one of those wars that they never make
a movie about the Spanish American war.
They never make a fucking movie about
that. And the Spanish American war.
Wasn't that the one we fought
in the fucking Philippines.
I always thought that that one was
like with Sam Houston and Dave Bowie.
David Bowie, now Daniel Boone,
whatever the fuck his name is, right.
They surrounded the Alamo.
Let's see this here.
Spanish American war.
What do you put the home game
away game. How do I look this up?
Serve or not found the fuck
you talking about. What again?
You motherfucker. Don't don't do
this to me. All right. This is,
this is how I fixed it. I shut it
off. Shut off Wifi. Turn Wifi back on.
That's like the fribulation. You're
fucking, I say that word right?
Come on. I feel like
Pachino in and he car guys.
Alright, here we go. Spanish American war.
I think this was in the Spanish
American war. Wikipedia.
God knows they're always right.
Spanish American war was a conflict
between Spain and the United States.
The result of the u s intervention in
Cuba. We've always been doing that, huh?
Well, we're trying to make
them free also. All right.
Location, Cuba, Puerto Rico,
the Philippines in Guam.
Why don't they ever make a movie
about that one? I'm sure they did,
but why don't they make a one that's
fucking known enough that I've seen it?
Hang on a second.
I know I've ever even read about this
was a conflict in 1898 between Spain and
the United States.
The results of US intervention
in the Cuban war of independence.
In other words, you know,
we, we always have a dog.
We always have a dog in the
fight. You know what I mean?
If we go to the fucking casino and
there's that gouge his fucking bet,
every game, that's the
United States, we always,
we always got some action going, you know,
walk around with our fucking
Hawaiian shirt and a big cigar.
Flip flops were a mess.
US attacks on Spain's Pacific coast. Oh,
Pacific positions led to the involvement
in the Philippine revolution and
ultimately to ultimately, ultimately
to the Philippine American war.
All right, let's click on
that Philippine American war.
It fucking lasted for
almost two over two years.
1899 three years. One
month. Oh, I'm sorry. Yeah,
that's three years. Jesus. Bill,
lay off the fucking sauce, Huh?
Um,
alright. Filipino civilians dead.
200 to 250,000 dead mostly from disease.
We lost four to 6,000.
They lost 12 to 20,000.
We crushed another one, Huh? Jesus Christ.
We were on a tear back. That was it.
That's what, that's when we
were really on a fucking tear.
Conflicts arose when first
Filipino republic objected
to the terms of the treaty
of Paris under which the United States
took possession of the Philippines from
Spain ending the Spanish American
war. Yeah. They're like, dude,
we want to be our own
people, if you don't mind.
And then we came over their land to the
home for a land of the brave free of the
home, whatever the fuck
our, our little tagline is.
I, and they probably scared up some
guy named fucking Ulysses, you know,
scared the shit out of. They're going
to come over here to go to kitchen.
They're going to get you
fucking four wheeler. Um,
anyways, once again, I don't even know
how the fuck I got to that goddamn thing.
Oh yeah. So the drink, it's called
the John Riley. All it is, it's,
it's a fucking Margarita.
And you take a shot at Jamison
and you'd dump it in there.
And it had something to do with the fact
that there was a bunch of Irish people
fighting on this side and
they decided, you know what,
you guys are fucking using us.
We're going to go fight on the
side where the Latinos are.
So that's the Jamieson going over
to the other fucking side. Right?
So now I got whiskey, the
bird, the real tailor.
The tape here is now I got what the
fuck's in a, in a, in a Margarita.
Okay. I never drink. Is that,
is that vodka or is it Tequila?
I think it's Tequila.
Right?
And uh, I fucking dumped
that in there. So now,
now I'm on my third fucking whiskey.
I had already ordered another Johnny
Black because it was a really long fucking
story. And now I'm three of those in, I
had a Jamison and then I had a fucking,
uh, a Margarita and a, I believe
I had one more after that grant,
I did all of this, I swear to
God it felt like 90 minutes,
but I think it was about two
and a half hours. And um,
then I did the Irish goodbye,
which is, I just hit me. He's like,
I got to get the fuck outta here.
And I didn't say goodbye to
anybody and I just walked.
Yeah.
They called my old friends La taxi.
That's who I always call. I do not Uber,
I don't do Uber because I
just, you know, you do Uber.
It's be some young kid,
he's in the fucking business and he's
going to hand you a fucking script or some
shit, you know? And eventually just
say something really creepy like, Oh,
you live here. You know? But yeah, you
get in the cab, it just like yellow.
Yes. Hello my friend. They don't give a
fuck. They don't, they have no fucking,
you know, they don't give a shit. They're
not trying to fucking do anything.
Right. So I call La taxi like, okay,
you know how many taxi you have Ababa?
And I'm just like, yeah, I just like,
yeah, I'm [inaudible].
And then that was just dead silence
it in my fucking head. It made,
they made me seem, made me think that
they knew where the fuck I was at.
I wasn't at the Ramada, I'm not going to
say what the fuck I was at. Right. So,
um,
then I was just standing there swaying
in the breeze and then one of my buddies
came down and his Uber pulled up and he
just saw me and he saw the state I was
in any, just let me get in it.
So I got in the fucking thing.
And like most streets in La, they're
the longest fucking streets ever.
You know what I mean?
Like last Sianna goes,
starts at the Hollywood hills and we'll
just go all the way down to like the
palace Verdi's peninsula. Maybe that one
doesn't, but some of them don't. They,
they're like, they're like
fucking 20 mile long streets,
so you have the north
side and the south side.
This guy started going in the wrong
fucking direction. Fortunately,
I wasn't so drunk,
he would've dropped me off to the
opposite end of the fucking, uh, you know,
fucking city or whatever.
And um, so I go to bed,
I don't even remember going to bed.
And then I wake up the next day I
woke up at like eight in the morning,
my dog fucking lick in my face and I
swear to God at eight in the morning,
I was still legally drunk, legally
drunk. And I was just like, oh my God.
So I got up, I walked
the dog around the block.
I sat down and I just fucking,
it took me till about 10 30 to get my
shit together and then I just walked all
the way back to the bar,
to the hotel area to get my fucking car.
Yeah,
just a complete waste of a fucking
day. By the time I got home,
it was like one in the afternoon.
And I'm just muttering to myself the
entire time going, look at this bill,
would you look at this?
Look how many fucking times
you got to learn this lesson.
And I would love to tell you that
this is the last time I'm going to do
something like that. It's the last
time for a while. Oh, is a bad one.
That was a bad bump. But you
know what was good was a,
I sold off some of the shit from my
garage and I got to tell you, felt good.
Made me want to get rid of a
bunch of more of my shit. Um,
I just got a ton of shit.
I don't know what I fuck.
And you know what it is and I'm telling
you, when I say shit, it's fucking shit.
Bunch of baseball hats and fucking
all these books and shit and just,
just stuff. Got All this
fucking shit and I'm sick of it.
It's all over the fucking
place. I don't use most of it,
so I'm, I'm, you know what,
I'm just gonna I'm going to
get rid of a bunch of shit. I,
I'm where I'm going to start to do is
every couple of days I'm going to give
something away or sell something on
Ebay and I literally want to get down to
basically bare bones.
What the fuck do I use?
You know, I was thinking about that
one on my long fucking walk of shame.
Back to my fucking car. I saw this giant,
we know all those may flower
moving trucks just as jai,
the biggest one you could possibly get.
Or they even have like in between
the front and the back wheels,
they drop the back end the trailer
down so they can even have shit down in
there. And I was just thinking like,
I never want to need one of those
ever. Okay.
You gotta be that guy that can fuck
the next size up from the u haul van.
That's what the fuck you need, right?
I want to be late. So,
uh,
oh, she's like a ton of shit to tell
you guys. So I also, I also want,
I looked at cars before my fucking,
my big, uh,
fucking booze fest and, uh,
I thought I finally found my
car and uh, I swear to God,
I love the picture of it. I
went and I looked at the 2016,
uh,
Cadillac Cts v await now though, the,
the top of the line one, whatever
the wanted, the one, it basically,
it goes fucking,
it goes 200 miles an hour and it's
a four door sedan. Right. And all,
all I'm thinking is that I'm, I'm just
like, all right, this is the fucking,
this is the one, it's exactly what
the fuck I want. I can't explain it.
I love the way it looks
like in the picture.
And then I went to go see it and it just
looked like something that you'd buy if
you were in, like if you
were in your twenties,
if you could somehow afford it
just with all the fins in the tail.
And of course I'm just like,
I can't get in my driveway because
the front end is too fucking low.
There's a little hump to get in my
driveway and then they go in like, well,
you could back it in. And um,
I don't know man. I just couldn't get
past. And then they were like, yeah,
Justin Bieber bought one of these.
And I'm like, yeah, exactly.
He should buy one of these. If
you could walk around shirtless,
putting one my eyebrow up and doing the
kissing your two fingers in the piece
thing, that's the fucking car for you.
I can as an almost 50 year old
fucking man walk in that thing.
I got to tell you, I
love the inside of it.
And it went like nine zillion miles an
hour. But I gotta admit I fucking, uh,
I realized while I was test driving the
car that I am an old man and I don't
like going fast. I just like cruising. So
I looked at the other Cadillacs like
the $54,000 fucking old man one,
it was 54 fucking thousand dollars and
I cannot stress enough what an absolute
piece of fucking shit it was. I could
have put my foot through the fucking door.
I literally left just like depressed.
I was just like, you know what?
Fuck this. Fuck all these fucking things.
I'm just going to keep driving my
fucking piece of Shit Prius. Right.
And it really is a piece of shit at this
point. Now the engine is fucking great,
but like I've had all the dents,
take it out and everything,
but it's sat in the sun for fucking
eight years. It's been hit too many.
It's punched drunk. My car
is fucking punch drunk.
So last night I'm at the
comedy store. Oh by the way,
the Lincoln New Lincoln
Continental's coming out in August,
2017 and it looks pretty fucking bad
ass. And it's just like, you know,
I was talking to a comic last night and
I was joking about how old I am that I,
I like comfort over speed at this
point. And he goes, oh yeah. He goes,
you know, you're out here in la cause
where the fuck are you going to?
Where are you gonna go? The fuck are
you going to go? You can't go anywhere.
You want comfort, you're
going to be stuck in traffic.
Just drive around in a living room and
it just totally made sense. It's like,
yeah, that's what the fuck I
want to do. Then of course,
I drive down to the club
that night, right? And all
of a sudden, I swear to God,
I don't know if every, these are a
bunch of tourists and they all rent,
rented the cars.
There was a fucking guy in a
white corvette like 2016 corvette,
a guy in a fucking 2016 brand
new fucking Ferrari, spider,
whatever the fuck that thing is. And
then somebody else with this, you know,
one of those BMW, the m ones,
m three m five or something,
and they're all zigzag and out of stop
and go traffic revving the engines and
all that shit. The exact thing that my
buddy was saying and I was going, look,
look how I was thinking that I'd
be thinking, look how dumb that is.
And all I was thinking was, look
how fucking great those cars look.
But of course everybody
in them was 20 something,
you know the Yolo guys,
Yolo shoes, right? I mean,
I just have to fucking old,
right? So, um, anyways,
so I went down to the store last night
comedy store and I fucking know I did a
set once again and I wasn't really
even funny last night. I mean,
I did a decent enough job.
I've been doing it long enough where
I can fake my way through my job,
but I just kept having brain farts and
all that cause I was still fucking hung
over. Right. So,
and when I'm hung over and
I'm kind of in a grouchy mood,
my shit goes from fucking silly to
like, dude, is this like a meeting?
This guy sounds like an
insane person. And, um,
I got out of the club and I
was walking in my car and uh,
this guy comes up, he goes,
excuse me, Mr Burr, Mr. Brewer.
And another reason why I shouldn't buy a
fucking cool sports car when somebody's
pushing 30 calls. You, Mr.
It's time to get yourself a Buick Riviera,
right though. You know what I mean?
Yeah. You can't fight it.
You can't fucking fight it.
I am in my sport coat luxury
car, you know, fucking years.
I'm going to go fucking,
I'm going to go online and buy an old
cutlets or something like that. Um,
old cutlets is actually a cool cone. Am
I talking about whatever, the fucking a,
a delta 88 or some shit. Um,
so he comes up and he's with his
girlfriend and uh, he goes, yeah,
I just want to say, you know,
I really enjoyed the show.
A big fan [inaudible] I got,
yeah, thanks. Or whatever.
And there's his just standing there.
She goes, yeah. She goes, I'm not a big,
she goes, yeah, I don't like you. Right.
Cause I was trashing the lays. Right.
She goes, I don't like you. And I go,
yeah, okay. I just went, all right.
And then she goes, no, I like you.
And she goes, I like you, but,
and I'm like, here we go. Here we go.
It's just like we just get on with
fucking trash and me, you know,
that fucking female manipulation
thing. She said, I don't like you,
cause she was expecting that I gave a
fuck. They'll be like, Ooh, you like me?
And then she could tell me what part of
my act she didn't like and guess what
part it was only this shit
about me, trash women,
all the other stuff was
perfectly fucking fine.
I'm talking about drunk driving
and going to McDonald's. Right.
She didn't have a fucking
problem with that.
All the hypothetically like innocent
people during that joke that I could have
fucking got in trouble, you
know, could have run over. Right.
She didn't give a fuck about that. So she
literally, she goes, I don't like you.
And I said, I'll coach.
She goes, no, I like you.
And then like a fucking
rookie. I stopped. She goes,
but you shouldn't be trashing him.
And it's just like, ah. I said,
I don't give a shit. I don't give
a fuck either. Dead after the show,
heckling is my number one pet peeve. I
stood on stage for 20 fucking minutes,
right in your crosshairs,
you know, yell out something.
Then you don't say shit.
You just fucking sit there.
And then after the show you come up to
me in the parking lot and you ignore the
30 topics. I went, I talked
about those, those were all fine.
And he'd just talk about the one that
pertains to you. So I just said, you know,
I don't give a shit, right. So
I get in my fucking car and she,
but at this point she was yelling at me,
um,
and this is hilarious. She goes, oh my
God, did I forget? She was like, man,
I don't have that. I wasn't
listening. And she goes,
and you drive a fucking Prius
steady yelling at me about my
car. Oh, it's fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious. She, when
she yelled fucking Prius,
she had turned around and
cause she realized that
wasn't going to listen to her
bitch moaning and
complaining about my jokes.
She had already turned away and she goes,
oh fuck. And she threw her head back.
She goes out, fucking
praise. And, uh, what she,
what she did there,
she made me laugh harder than I probably
made the whole crowd laugh my entire
set in that moment. So thank
you to that woman. And uh,
you know, other than that, you know, I
don't know what to tell you next time.
Heckled me onstage and, and I'll
listen to what you have to say.
There was a fucking woman
had called me in the crowd,
although I'll tell you how
to rough one, you know. Um,
yeah, I don't know what the fuck to
tell you. Um, all right. Before I,
before I end voice, start doing
some of these reads here. Uh,
what the fuck is it? Yeah.
Five dogs from tribe
called quest passed away.
Man. I was one of the, a casual of that,
you know, I'm just too fucking white.
I missed it. I totally missed
the boat. You know, I saw
Michael Rappaport's documentary on
him and I'll just maybe feels like,
how the fuck did I miss
this shit? Oh, that's right.
Cause I was listening to warrant.
I got it man, that fuck it. But I,
even though I didn't listen to
the band as much as I should have,
it really forced fucking depressing. Um,
just cause I obviously had friends die
at that fucking age from that shit.
Complications of diabetes and
all that. So, uh, I dunno,
that's just getting old.
Sucks. Just fucking blows.
45 years old. How the fuck do you
come to terms with that? You know,
why did I bring it up? I knew it was
going to be depressing. All right,
let's read some advertising.
All right. Score big. Uh,
you're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups in last minute
convenience charges. Oh, by the way,
you know I asked this before,
how the fuck is there a way that I can
sell tickets to my show just off my
website and only fans will get them.
Like what stops these people who go in
and somehow cause they got the money,
we'll go out and buy like 500 fucking
tickets and then jack the price up and
then everybody gives me shit
on the Internet. Go Look,
do you phone you not this funny.
And then they show how much the tickets
are for and the amount of times I call
my age and going to what the fuck
are we doing here? And he's like,
that's not us.
That's those constant buy a thousand
tickets and then rape everybody.
If anybody knows a way.
You know what's hilarious?
I think this advertising might be the way.
I have no idea between all the markups
that you know with these guys at doing.
These guys are going to undercut stub hub.
This is actually probably a
good thing here. All right.
I'm not saying these guys
aren't dirt bags too,
but you know you can't just have one dirt
bag. You know if you get to dirt bags,
they start fucking going at each other
and then you slide under the radar.
Right? Anyway,
she paid too much for tickets between
all the markups and last minute
convenience charges. Even print
at home fees. Question Mark.
Exclamation point.
You can end up paying court side prices
for nosebleed seats score big.com is
here to change that. Well,
well, well let's see.
Let's see you guys. You guys check this
thing out. Let me know if this is legit.
Did you know that 40% of all live event
tickets go on sold and did you know that
there's a place to get these seats at
huge savings? It's called score big.com.
In other words, you bought
up 40% of the tickets.
What do you mean they go
on sold? No, they don't.
Yeah.
Well they don't, this is all bullshit.
40% go on. Sold. Yeah. And
then you know what they do?
They probably would
fucking cancel the show.
The acts not making the venue any money.
All right. You know what? I'll, I'll,
I'll, I'll suspend
disbelief here. You know,
considering Batman versus Superman is
going to be coming out this week and you
gotta suspend all that disbelief that a
guy from another fucking planet that can
fly and bullets bon off
his bounce off his chest.
He's gonna have a fucking fight against
a regular human being who has a fucking
utility belt,
right?
Bullets bounce off his chest.
What is Batman going to?
What does he have in his little fucking
tool belt there that can fuck with that
guy?
If they really made this movie as real
as possible, Batman versus Superman, it,
it's going to go down like one of those
old school Mike Tyson paper views.
Remember that the fight would be over
before the pizza showed up. But you know,
somehow they'll, they'll
fucking, I dunno what they'll do.
They'll keep it going. I love
how they are out of victims.
They're out at like villains and
now they have to fight each other.
You know what I mean? Like what
does that say about superheroes?
You know what I mean? I think
that just they just into fighting.
They don't give a fuck whether
somebody's good or bad. They just,
they just need,
they need to fight somebody and then when
they stop all the crime and you think
they're going to relax and get themselves
the new 2017 Lincoln continental,
you know, maybe chill on the
whole flying and all that stuff.
Get themselves some adult
clothes, right? What do they do?
They start fighting each other.
Fucking animals. All right.
Score big works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get their
unsold
seats@atunpublishedpricesonlyatscorebig.com
can
you
name
a
ticket
price
and
be
guaranteed to pay below box office
up to 60% off the fuck outta here.
Here's what you do. How are you
undercutting the venue? One.
Go to scorebig.com and
find the event and seats.
You want to make an offer with the score.
Biggs name a ticket price feature.
17 get an instant answer and
save up to 60% on your tickets.
No surprise fees and free shipping.
Just unbeatable prices on great seats.
And when you, you're in great seats,
you actually enjoy the game
or show all the more, well,
I hope these guys are legit. Next time
you go to see any shoe game or show,
go to score big first to
see how much they can save.
Go to score big.com right now.
Click even if you don't have a show
you want to go to, just go to it.
Click on the microphone,
enter the Promo Code Bar and you'll
save an extra $20 off your first ticket
purchase@scorebig.com Promo Code
Bar Score, big.com promo code bar.
Oh look who's back. Look who's back.
Speaking of the Spanish American
war club, Kellyanne clump, Debbie,
I'm a warp time. Praise.
Uh, we've all been there.
You come home after a long exhausting day
at work and all you want to do is slip
a glass slip, slip, sip a quarter,
my Cosby sip a glass of wine.
Slip a fucking roofie and somebody
want sip a glass of wine and relax.
But unless you've planned ahead,
you probably don't have a bottle in your
house and getting up and going to the
store is not happening. Uh,
with club Debbie Winter Red Tag,
I'm on the Red Tag-team. You can add,
you can finally relax because you'll
never have to worry about being wined free
again. Clip Debbie, I'm
better than Jim Jam.
Couldn't make it through the primaries
is a new wine club that sends you wine
directly to your door, saving you
all those trips to the grocery store.
Not only this club. Debbie, I'm
going to stop here one more time.
Praise and evil doers. Send
your wine, send you wine,
they'll send you wine that you'll
love drinking club. Debbie,
let me introduce you to my little
brother, older brother, GM.
He's not as good as me. Easy six
question quiz figures out your palate.
So every bottle you receive is perfectly
tailored to your tastes. Clip, Debbie,
he's doing it being an alcoholic.
Now I can speak Spanish,
works directly with the vine
vineyards to cut out the middlemen,
which saves you money club, Debbie,
I've got no more George Bush jokes even
offers a no risk guarantee that you'll
love what they said you call the action
offer right now. Club Debbie, come up.
Debbie, you knew what I was in
2000. He still reelected me in 2004.
How Doma you is offering listeners $20
off your first order when you go to club
Debbie, Dick Cheney really ran the whole
thing.com/burn and yet
it gets even better.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club Debbie will actually pay for your
shipping on orders of four bottles or
more. So it takes something off
your to do list. Just go to club w.
Dot com slash bird and get $20 off your
first order now at [inaudible] dot com
slash burr fool me once.
Shame on you for me twice.
You're not good for me. Um,
all right. Is that the fucking
podcast here for this week? Yes.
I believe checking in on your,
they'll checking in on your podcast.
Let me guys let me know. Um, I
know I shit on that sponsor a lot.
They're probably not going to
advertise me anymore, but you know.
Okay.
Yeah. You know, it's shit happens.
Um, the fuck do I just
have a socket here for
anyways? Um, yeah, so I'm going to
start selling some shit on Ebay and uh,
I was actually thinking that this is
not much, I want to start selling shit.
I was thinking of fucking taking my truck
out to my shows this weekend and just
bringing a bunch of shit in the
back and it just shit, you know,
shit to me, somebody else might
like it, the end of the show,
just fucking given it to people, you know,
just getting it Outta here and then
somebody else takes it and they like it
because if I throw it out, it
ends up in the fucking ocean.
But if I fucking just give it to
somebody, they can keep it in, in their,
in their bedroom or in their fucking
living room, away from the poor purses.
Um,
I know it's just an idea. Just an idea.
I've decided I'm going to start with
the fucking closet in my, in my bedroom.
I'm just going to go in there. I want
to, I'm going to have two fucking piles.
Shit.
I need shit I don't need and
I'm going to write on a post it,
stop being a sentimental
bitch. Get rid of this shit.
Whatever I need to do to just fucking
plow through and get rid of all of this
stuff because I'm
okay.
I'm not, I don't, I don't, I just don't
want all this shit anymore. All right.
That's it. That's the podcast this
week. You guys have a wonderful weekend,
Yukon and I'll, uh, I'll
talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] everybody
[inaudible]
and that is, it built a bit
of a dilemma here for you. Uh,
I'm an 18 year old male who's
about to graduate from high school.
Congratulations. Um,
over the past few years,
I've been told I'm a really good
dancer. Uh, not ballet or artsy stuff,
but just good dance
floor dancing. Oh my God,
I'm going to take over the dance
floor. Hey Angie, watch me.
You're John Travolta. This is great.
Do you go out to the Staten Island
Bridge and do headstands with your,
with your buddy Bobby? You
know, if he didn't have an Afro,
he never would've fell off that
bridge if he had it high and tight.
Like all these Armenians out here, all,
every Armenian looks like they know, uh,
they, they know, um, um, MMA moose.
Last time you saw in our Armenian
dude in his twenties or thirties,
and he did not look like he could put
you in an arm bar within two seconds if
you wanted to. If I was,
if I was a Dana white and I was
running the UFC at one point,
that this point, whether
they're up to like what,
like UFC 2006,
they're like running, they'd run out
of adjectives this time. It's really,
really personal, right? Not Saying
I'm not a fan of a huge fucking fan.
I'm just saying, you know,
the way they had those things like every
other week and there's only so many
like you know, redemption. I mean
you're running out of words. Um,
I'm such a fucking idiot.
This is what I would do if I was dating
a white at some point I would have,
you know, you know what I would,
this is what I would branch off.
And when they had those
tough man competitions and
they would have just people
coming in,
throwing haymakers which is some of
the best boxing ever is when you watch
people who just aren't trained
whatsoever and they just start, you know,
cause somebody's going to connect, right.
I think that they should have one week
they should have the Armenians verse the
Russians tough man competition because
I really think that that meets,
it needs to be decided who is
the tougher of the two. Uh,
cause when I, when it comes
to white people, that's,
that's who I got my money
on. All right. That those,
those are the crips and the bloods of
white people is the army and the Russians,
all of them, they just have that
vibe that somebody just like, yeah,
I'm a fucking with that guy. Just
really, I'm really not doing it anyways.
Uh, not a ballet or artsy stuff. Uh,
but just ballroom dates in a fucking,
you know, uh,
I kind of think of think dancing is
gay from an outside point of view.
Um, I, it isn't, it really isn't,
that's just how white people look at it.
It's considered gay cause it involves
like letting yourself go and actually
admitting that you have emotions as a
man, as a white male. Yeah. It's, yeah,
it is. It's considered gay. Um,
as his crying as his showing any sort
of emotion as is not dying for no good
goddamn reason before you're 56,
um, or not dying, I should say.
If you live to be 60, I believe amongst
white men, that's also considered gay.
Cause that means at some point you cried
something out of your chest and you
didn't have a heart attack.
Um, anyways, he says,
I think dancing is gay from
an outside point of view,
but I'll be the first one to admit that
I'm actually a pretty good dancer if I
didn't think so. I wouldn't be out
there doing it. Yeah, but dude,
you gotta be getting some, I'll, I'll
fucking women love a guy who can dance,
but if you can dance and you're wearing
like a silk scarf, it's fucking over.
It's going to be rain and pussy.
As far as my outside view,
my freckled view from over in the bar
trying to stand out from underneath those
hot lights so I don't
get burned. Uh, you know,
red heads with the closest
thing to vampires, you know,
we have, we have none of
the powers of vampires,
but the sun affects us the same.
Okay.
A friend of mine who was a female dancer
keeps telling me I could make money
doing it on commercials or music videos,
parentheses clothes on.
Or You could go to fucking Broadway and
be like one of the five straight men who
dances on Broadway and just tag every
fucking lonely chick out there who's all
stretched out. Just make
sure you keep their shoes on.
Dancer's feet are always fucked up.
Uh, here's where it gets complicated.
I plan on becoming a policeman. Oh
Dude, this is, this is a no brainer.
You need to dance it. Bachelorette parties
dressed as a cop. All you need, dude,
is that a fake uniform on a boombox
and you're on your way to making money?
Dude, you should fucking
do that in a second.
And then you write a book about it.
I was a gyrate and cop
for Bachelorette parties.
You write a tell all book about how
many fucking broads you bought. Ready?
Got Married, go get married, suck your
Dick. You really need help on this one.
I mean, I'm going to read the rest of it,
but I think I've already come
with the solution anyways.
How is anyone to take me
seriously on the force?
If there's a video going with me,
pop and locking next to little Wayne.
At the same time, I'll, dude, you
should fucking pull people over.
You should pull people over and fucking
moonwalk up to their car and just freak
them out. Even if they
were reaching for a gun,
they'd be laughing too
hard and they, they,
they wouldn't shoot you then you
could rest them and then you move up.
Next thing you know, you're a
commissioner, right? Nothing. Anyways,
at the same time, I'm getting laid a
lot because of it. Of course you are.
I'm a seven on a scale of 10. I
like this guy's honest and um, uh,
and like having a jumpshot. It's
put me up to an eight, five.
I'm bang intense. I've always wanted
to be a cop at the parks here.
Seen better if I was able to make money
doing it other in the dancing thing,
I wouldn't just be getting hammers
for letting gross moms off on speeding
tickets. I could be banging
J-lo. She's into dancers, right?
Thanks. Yeah. Dude. APP's
a fucking lutely dude.
You're basically saying,
what should I do here?
Should I bang j Lo's beat down at the
club and make all this fucking money or
should I take a job where I'm going
to get shot at and not be appreciated.
Okay.
You know, I'll tell you every cop
out there with dance if they could,
as opposed to being a cop, I don't care
if they're like seven generations in,
dude, this is what I think of as
far as like dancing. I think if I,
if I,
okay.
Like compare it to being a comedian. Oh,
the open mikes would be getting a piece
of cardboard and being on a subway
platform, making money that way.
And then when you move up to hosting
a show, that would be your dresses,
a cop and you fucking dance
at Bachelorette parties.
That's what you do on the side. That's
like your fucking day job. That bullshit.
And then during the day, I, yeah, I
would try out for those. Fuck, I don't,
do they make music videos
anymore or fucking, uh,
I dunno. I believe it or not, I don't
know how to climb the ladder as a dancer,
but dude, APP's a fucking lutely.
If you can make money doing that shit.
And then what the great thing is, is
once you get to a certain level to, to,
uh, make more money, you know, once
you got some credibility, you can,
you always have the fallback where you
can teach a class. They, you can be like,
I danced for nine years and Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang and fucking banged every
fucking broad on there.
And then if you'd like to know how to
fuck the women in your cast while still
not losing your job, come on down the
Frankie's in Dade Studio, whatever.
Just you'll figure it out
as you go in there. And, um,
yeah, absolutely. Absolute fucking
Lulea. I would definitely do it.
You want to do what you
want and taking the time,
um,
to write in. So your big fears, should
we be whatever, everybody's big fears.
Like what if I go after this dream and
I'm 30 and I'm sleeping on a fucking
futon and it hasn't happened yet.
Well, I gotta tell you something, sir.
I'd been there. I was there at fucking 34.
I was still sleeping on a futon and a
fucking studio apartment that they call
the one bedroom because they
slammed a fucking wall in there
and put a door on it.
And then one day I was trying to bang
the girl upstairs who had the fucking
apartment right above me, and
it was the exact same unit.
And hers was a studio,
but she had been there longer so
they never slammed a wall in there.
And I realized, Hey, wait a minute,
I'm getting fucked. You know,
I should go down there and try and
get some money taken off of this.
I should go down to the a. They're fucking
me over rental board. But I didn't.
I said, fuck it. Just
keep writing jokes, right.
So whatever all you've got to do,
you've just got to commit to this shit
and uh, and then realize that, you know,
sleep on Futon when you're 30 is
not the worst thing. It isn't.
You don't see what you don't. It's
worse to sleeping on Futon at 30,
sleeping in a king bed next to a fucking
woman you're not really love with.
But for some reason married and a,
you got a couple of kids and you got
a job that you fucking hate. Okay.
You'll be laying there fantasizing about
fucking sleeping on a, on a, on a, uh,
on a futon there, there is no risk.
When you go after a dream,
it's all fucking reward.
It's all going to lead to
something good. It always does.
There's a tremendous amount of
risk to playing it safe and uh,
that leads to unbelievable
levels of regret,
which is something else I've also
experienced. Cause I'm an old [inaudible]
mother, motherfucker.
Well in the city, believe you.
Every day is pretty much
[inaudible] I be happy.
Surprise. We're getting a divorce. All
right, here's a new story. All right.
Hey Bill, I know you have,
you aren't a therapist,
but I think I just want to talk to
anyone at this point. So here goes,
I've been married for just under four
years to my wife who I dated for four
years prior to marriage. I love being
married and have said that to anyone. Uh,
that asked since day one, we own a nice
house together. We have three dogs,
pit bulls, two good man and
both make a decent living.
I share everything in my life with my
wife. Uh, when something makes me happy,
she knows when I'm upset about
something. I tell her, uh,
throughout the course of our relationship
about once a year she would suddenly
without warning say she,
she was unhappy and has been for months.
Okay. Here we go. Okay.
She says she has discussions with their
mom who loves me and is the sweetest
woman alive and close friends about
the things that make her unhappy by,
I never hear a word about it until it
boils over and she floors me with how
unhappy she is. Well,
that's not fair. All right.
We tried to work it out
though. Make changes.
She would act like it was okay
while it bottling it up again once,
once the lid goes on the bottle,
there's no opening it again.
Each and every time she
calls the unhappiness state
of the Union meeting into
session.
I've always been completely honest as
saying that I'm very happy with her.
I love our jokes and honesty and joy.
Honestly enjoy spending time at Bahbahbah
Jesus Christ to get to the fucking
point. All right, last
Wednesday, here we go.
We had a good night together.
We went out for dinner and ice cream
and laughed at about Alibaba by bar.
So I thought I'd come home the
following night in general, great mood.
And she told me she had talked to her
mom and a friend and that they recommend
that she talks to me. I was
confused, Eh Damn. Oh Shit.
About not being unhappy. Uh, anyways,
I wanted anything to make her happy,
but she told me she didn't
think there was anything.
It was very emotional as she finally
mustered up the courage to say that we
might need to get separated.
I was floored and not in an almond
asshole husband that sits around drinks,
beer and watches football with his
buddy way. I love my wife. We have free.
Okay Dude. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Uh,
so the following day
after much reluctance,
I get her to agree to try
marriage counseling so we
can work out our happiness
do, and I'm not giving
you shit that this is,
you're pouring your heart out because
this shit just happened. I understand.
But for the sake of the listeners,
I got to put fly through this. Um,
I get to agree with her. I get to, I
get it. Okay. So the following day,
it's like Lord of the rings
here, after much reluctance,
I get her to agree to try marriage
counseling so we can work out her
unhappiness. I was willing
to do anything at this point.
I immediately scheduled an appointment
with the counselor and was looking
forward to having someone
neutral for us to talk to.
Later that night we were laying in bed
and I asked her if there was someone else
in her life. She said, no. Yeah
Dude. Oh Jesus. Oh, Jesus. Uh,
Jesus, here we go. We just went over
the waterfall folks or where we,
you know what it is
now? No. In this story,
we were hearing the waterfall and we just
looked at the other person in the RAF
with the panic.
Look on our face for that split
second before we tried to desperately.
But futilely try and paddle the fucking
thing over to the Goddamn coast.
Okay, here we go. We're going over.
I got a feeling we're going over.
Um, she said, no, there's
no one else in my life.
I asked her if she's ever been unfaithful
in our relationship relationship and
she adamantly said no again.
Then she turned out the
light and laid down to sleep.
Five minutes later she sat up
and turn the light on a fuck.
She told me she just lied to me and said
that she had messed around with someone
a year into our marriage. And he
writes in capital letters, what period?
The period fuck period.
I probed her to tell me what messing
around was as got at least be at blowjob.
Okay.
Oh, ah, fucking whore. Um,
and after a minute of me guessing
her silence told me that she went in
down on a guy, she works
with, swear to God.
I had read this.
Okay.
Oh, if I was very busy right now. Yeah.
What I say, you heard me, you heard me
fast. Fucking creek. I
was furious and hurt.
Then furious again. She cried
and cried and said she was sorry.
We cried together. Dude,
you're a bigger man than me.
While I tried to wrap my head around
how she could possibly have done that to
me, I've had casual flirting
with people over the years,
but to act on something physically
with someone other than your spouses,
completely disgusting. To me,
the worst part is I love this woman
more than anyone. She's been my og.
Here we go again. She's not my best
friend for the last eight years.
She knows everything about me.
I want to hate her and make her sleep
at her parents house until we divorced.
But all I want to do is, yeah, be near
her again. Yeah, Dude. Let's, because
yeah, dude, she, she was in the hurry
up offense. That's what happened here.
So now you're scamper and trying to
figure out what the fuck is going on.
And she, you know, she has an x three
place that she just called in the huddle.
That's why this, this is why it
sucks to be you right now. Um,
one of my close friends tells me what
I know is the right thing. He goes,
let it go. Don't bother with clown.
Silene what else has she done that you
don't know about how he never trusted her
again? Bill, is it possible for me to
forgive my wife? Am I wasting my time?
Um, also I find out who this guy is
and I really wish I hadn't. Yeah, dude,
of course. All I wanted to do was show
up at the job, beat the shit out of him.
Like Ed Norton, Pete's the blonde,
pretty boy up in fight club. He writes,
I wanted to destroy something beautiful.
My other thought is since this guy
also cheated on his girlfriend,
who we still with, um,
he did it with my wife.
I threatened to tell his girlfriend what
he'd done but not actually do it. Yeah.
You don't want to do that that way.
He live in fear of coming home and her
knowing everything because I told her or
he would try to beat me
to it and admit to it,
hopefully ending his relationship
and getting terminal cancer and aids,
terminal cancer and aids. And you know
what? You're still being a gentleman.
I still think that you're,
you're handling this with class wishing
terminal cancer and AIDS on this guy.
Um, I know you don't give a
shit. Of course I give a shit,
but not occupy a, but I've
got to occupy my mind. So I,
I thought I do it here. Yeah. Dude, why
would you think I don't give a shit?
You know, I mean, I'm not a friend
of yours, but you know what I mean?
Give me a fucking break. This
is horrific. Um, all right.
Your first question builds it
possible for me to forgive my wife. A,
eventually you're going to have to, uh,
and or you're going to go on a fucking
tear and you're going to meet some really
damaged fucking women and they're gonna
reinforce everything that you've now
found out about your wife. See, can't
do that. You're going to go on a fucking
a hate fuck pussy spree. That is, yeah.
You don't want to do that. Um, you
said, am I wasting my time? Yeah, dude,
it's over. She's not happy.
She's not good at communicating.
Um, she puts a lid on it, you know, until
it boils over. This is the deal, dude.
You know what I, this is
going to kill you. All right,
let's go with the positive. You
don't have any kids with her. Okay?
You can just walk away. Okay.
We had a prop and there was a, there's
nothing we could do. It's over.
He didn't make it. Did you just fucking
walk away? Just walk away. It's over.
All right. Um, that's a good
thing. All right. One thing.
You've had a bunch of
kids with his fucking,
this person who for whatever
reason, couldn't say that they will.
I don't think that she wanted
even wanting to fucking marry you.
I think she ignores her feelings.
She's actually having a
fucking breakthrough right
now while stomping all over
your fucking heart. All right, well
I dunno. I don't know. I don't fuck her.
Give me a break, dude. You fucking,
you loved her with all your heart.
You say a mother's a sweetheart. You
got dogs. You like communicating dude.
You know something your like
the fucking guy. You're the guy.
My girl wants me to be. Every
fucking woman wants a guy like that.
You know guy who actually wants to be
married guy who actually comes home and
communicates,
you know a guy who gets along with
the mom and all that type of shit.
You're a family man. All
right. Unfortunately,
you know you met the wrong
person, so forget that dude.
All right. Forget it. Forget it. Fuck
that. Fuck dead. It's over. Walk away.
Well, walk away dude.
Give me a fuck about you.
You know what you're talking about
there. You're talking about like the,
the amount of fucking shit she has to
go through before she even learns how to
just communicate her fucking emotions
and the frustration of that's going to
meet every once in a while she's
going to blow somebody at work.
Are you wasting your time?
APP's a fucking Luli. Okay.
Apps of Fucking Luli.
And as far as like going there and
trying to fuck over that other guy,
that other guy is, he's already,
you don't need to fuck him over.
He's fucking himself over. He's living,
he's living a life of misery.
That life is miserable to fuck
around with the person that you with,
with somebody else. That
is a miserable life.
You know, I don't know.
They get something that a lot of guys do.
Myself included back in the day in my
twenties going into the thirties trying to
fucking, uh, you know, figure
myself out. I lived that life,
that whole fucking double. It's
horrible. It's a fucking horrible thing.
Then in the end,
I ended up alone and I heard a lot of
people and I was a complete piece of shit.
So, and believe me, dude,
it was miserable and ended up
with me on a fucking futon.
Um, yeah, dude, you're, you're, you know,
don't become a piece of shit. Now.
Don't judge other women like that.
Just fuck it. You know?
Yeah. Get out of it.
Get out of it and just know
that it's gonna be a fucking a,
I dunno,
it's gonna be a hundred yards of pain
that you never fucking dealt with in your
life and you just gotta
go through it. And, um,
I would say the next time you
get with somebody, uh, make,
you know you're going to get serious with
somebody who would make God damn sure
that they know how to fucking
communicate, because that's a,
that's a scary thing to get with a woman
who does not communicate because that's
something that they're supposed
to teach us how to do. You know,
in a way they make you better
because you, oh, all I can just say,
uh, no, I don't feel like doing that
without fucking punched in the wall.
You know, they do that set of sell
you down if you get with some psycho.
And she can't settle you down. I
mean, she's a, she's damaged Chris
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
all right. 27 year old
Virgin Jesus Christ.
Hey Billy, I'd love to hear your
humorous take on my pathetic situation.
First of all, dude, let's work
on yourself estate. All right.
You're already shitting all over
yourself. I'm all right. Watch this guy.
Watch him shit all over himself. I'm
a 27 year old virgin. Oh geesh. Uh,
that's what he wrote.
Now your first question is going to
be how the fuck did that happen? Well,
to protect myself,
I'd actually preserved prefer to keep
my background as quiet as possible. Hey,
I'm not trying to get you to rat
yourself out. Here's what I can say.
I come from a rich town inhabited by
obnoxious cause I was always the weird kid
and very socially awkward people
hated me no matter how nice I was.
Jesus Christ. Dude,
are you like a superhero that's like
the exact same background of like every
fucking superhero movie, isn't
it? Probably Cause Nerds, right?
Those movies cause they don't have to
fight and all of a sudden you're like,
what am I knew how to play? What am I
could fly? I was a guy who could save me.
Um,
and then they draw it and then nerds
line up around the block to go see it.
New Spiderman. Yes. It's
exactly the other ones. Um,
I was always the weird kid and very
socially awkward people hated me no matter
how nice I was. And eventually I
came to hate myself and still do.
I called it dude, I fucking called
it a, he's shitting all over himself.
Eventually it was discovered that I most
likely have a mild case of Asperger's
syndrome, which is a mild form of
autism, which is way out of my league.
Are you guys trying to make me
look dumb? I thought I did that.
I achieved that by how
awful. I read out loud.
[inaudible]
here we go. That causes social ineptitude
and Quirky personality traits. Well,
I would go find a hooker with asbergers.
That's the first thing I would do.
You get the Fucking v off my
back. Definitely wear a condom.
See that's where my advice
is going to be coming from.
You guys have some weird
conversation in some ironic vehicle.
I'm at least discovering this made me
more of self-aware and I've been able to
clean up my act over the last few years,
but I still have a lot of social anxiety
and shyness and very few friends.
On the flip side, I'm actually
pretty decent looking,
have a decent job in a
laboratory. He's a fucking,
he's going to get bit by something
radioactive and he's going to become a
superhero. Uh,
and I'm a certified commercial
pilot and do volunteer work
dude. Like you know something.
If, if I was in the FBI,
like so many fucking red flags
just went up there. Uh, okay.
That's the set up now.
Now for the question
first, what the fuck would you
do if you were in my situation?
I told you I'd get a hooker
with Asperger's syndrome
and you guys could just
bond over that. Uh, I
don't know. Let, let me,
let me read all your questions.
I'm obviously kidding off trying to find
a hook with Asperger system syndrome.
All right. You couldn't find one that
would be like a needle in a haystack,
which you'd have to do is go to an escort
service and request that personally.
Um, I would think
I'm looking for 36, 24 36 with Asperger.
Okay.
Hair color does not matter. Yes,
I can hold 'em next if ever.
If eventually everything I ever do
make it anywhere with the chick.
Should I tell her up
front about my status?
I had this conversation a few weeks ago
with a friend who has a lot of romantic
experience and she said it would be
extremely obvious that I'm new to the game
and that withholding that information
could itself be detrimental.
But I also know that if I do tell
a chicken 27 year old virgin,
she will demand an explanation before
going any further and it will send up red
flags for the most. What do you do?
Built thanks to doing your awesome
podcast and go fuck yourself. All right,
this is what I would do.
I would just start hitting on every check
that fucking interests me and I would
be just totally honest. Tell him,
tell her what your, your, uh,
your situation is. And uh, you know,
if she doesn't accept it,
then fucker let her walk and then you
don't have to deal with any of the
bullshit. You didn't or you just,
you just fast forward through a three
year fucking horrific relationship. Um,
I would just be upfront with people.
I wouldn't open it with a at you have
beautiful eyes and I have Asperger.
I wouldn't do that, you know? Um,
I would work on my self esteem.
I wouldn't talk shit. You just, you
shit on yourself right out of the gate.
I mean,
obviously I knew you're going to do
that when you said you were 27 year old
virgin and you probably going
to go that route, but uh,
think good thoughts about yourself,
man. I know that's kind of like simple,
but I, you know, you gotta like you
got to amp yourself up a little bit,
go out there and you know, you
don't have to go find the check.
He had drains but just go out.
You don't get to tell some girl he got
fucking Asperger syndrome. You don't,
why don't you just do that with somebody
that you're really interested in but it
just want to go out and get laid. Just
go out there, start hitting on checks,
turn it into a game so you don't have
to deal with the pain of the rejection.
Just be like, alright, I don't have
the balls to take the next step.
Whatever that step is. Peeling
yourself off the fucking wall.
Striking up a conversation, just
saying hello to a pretty girl.
She walks down the street.
Just try to get over that fucking hurdle
and give you permit yourself permission
to suck and you just, you
gradually build it up.
It's like learning how to play guitar.
You're not going to pick it
up and immediately be able
to play all your songs.
You learned a couple of fucking chords,
you know? Then your fingers hurt, right?
And you get frustrated,
but you keep coming back and
eventually you can fucking play.
Pussy is no different.
That's what I would do. Put the Asperger
on the back burner. Who knows too.
Maybe not as fucked up as you think you
are socially. You know what? I mean,
maybe you got a sense of humor under that.
I think you do your shit on
yourself in a funny way. You know,
spin it around that way. Do you
have any interests? Go, go to, oh,
go to a fucking, I dunno,
whatever. You know, you fly kites,
go to some flying again in the code
convention. There's gotta be
some woman there also likes Kate.
I know that was an overly simplified
thing, but that's what I would do.
All right.
And then when you go to like a
hookup with somebody, a nice,
you know, NGS, tell them
if he start and you're not,
don't know what you're doing to watch
a couple of fucking pornos, you know,
you'll get the idea. Actually,
no, don't do that. Don't do that.
Cause then you'll suck. Just start
slapping them around. You don't do that.
I know what to tell you, dude. I get
buy some books. I say go buy some,
buy some books and that, that, uh,
that, that part of the bookstore that,
you know, if, if bookstores
exist anymore, go on, go online.
There's gotta be plenty
of information. I bet.
If you literally looked up finger banging
technique, if you looked how to kiss,
I bet this is going to be
reams of fucking information.
I've never done that because I never had
to. Oh, just kidding. Of course I had.
Do you think that I've been wished that
fucking information was around way back
in the day when he had no id,
just practice kissing your fucking pillow
and tried to overhear conversations in
the fucking high school cafeteria and try
to figure out what people were talking
about. That's all I could do. You, you
have the whole world that you fingertips,
you know?
So when you're done in the laboratory
working with radioactive shit before you,
you get bit by something you don't
want you to go on and get late.
Okay.
Before you learned how to
fly. Alright. All right.
[inaudible].